according to the labor department
employers added 431 000 jobs this is
nationwide just last month and that
marks the 15th month in a row of job
gains hiring and leisure and hospitality
are leading those gains but despite
there being more jobs some employers say
it's still really hard to fill those
positions joe moeller spoke to some
business owners about what they are now
experiencing he joins us live joe's near
paradise and flamingo
employers thought this problem would be
over by now many of them say it's hard
to find the right person for the right
job and some
places are getting creative silver
silver 7's casino here at flamingo and
paradise is offering
incentives like many others are starting
to do
the customer also has been more patient
with us sami ledecky just opened toasted
it is a breakfast and lunch spot in the
southwest valley he says he is hiring if
you know someone sent him here while it
isn't impossible to find help he says it
is not as easy as it once was i don't
know what these people went
i'm just wondering online it is easy to
spot job openings offering hiring
bonuses the city of north las vegas is
offering bonuses for pool staff the
cosmopolitan is hosting a job fair next
week take a look they are also offering
bonuses george malouf owns a number of
ben and jerry ice cream shops around the
valley i think just the quality of
applicants has gone down he says it is
tough he has made changes making
promotions easier for employees to move
up we have an entry level position
and then you know within
a month or two they can give themselves
a raise by taking out some additional
responsibilities and we've got like
three or four levels some businesses
have realized employees are looking for
improved work environments i think the
pandemic definitely
re-shifted people's focus on what's like
really important ingrid and alfonza
rozar from entertainment labor force
we're trying to do is be leaders more
than we are bosses from training to
being more personable to employees they
say they are focused on improving the
work environment to keep workers we want
them to choose us not because it's a
need
or because they have to it's because
they want to work with us
and now back out here live one business
owner that i talked to says regardless
if he's hiring at that exact moment or
not he leaves that now hiring sign out
there just in case because coming across
our qualified applicants has not been
easy reporting live joe mulder live
local now